la dernière fois on a vu que la justice
était un outil efficace pour créer des
incentives qui pousse les gens à bien se
comporter
mais quand même nous attendent il n'a
généralement pas besoin du couperet de
la justice pour se comporter de façon
morale après tout quand on utilise des
toilettes publiques la tendance à tirer
la chasse d'eau même si personne ne nous
punira pour ne pas l'avoir fait deux
gars moi je dire un chef d'eau pire
encore dans d'autres cas faire ce qui
est moral peut avoir un coût énorme
par exemple qu'un exemple en tête
stéphane en 2006 l'écrivain allemand
günter grass prix nobel de littérature
admis avoir servi dans la waffen ss
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale cette
révélation fait scandale non seulement
l'écrivain avait caché ce secret pendant
plus de 50 ans mais en plus il s'était
permis à de nombreuses reprises de
critiquer son pays pour ne pas savoir
faire face à son passé nazi alors qu'il
aurait très bien pu cacher ce secret
jusqu'à sa mort l'écrivain a choisi de
complètement détruire sa réputation
morale jusque là exemplaire
comment expliquer ce type de
comportement si ce n'est pour des
raisons morales et cette histoire
illustre très bien une caractéristique
importante et des comportements moraux
les comportements moraux nous font faire
des choses qui nous desservent des
choses qui vont à l'encontre de nos
intérêts personnels et ce à assabou d'un
énorme problème aux biologistes de
l'évolution et aux chercheurs en
biologie évolutionnaire comme stéphane
en biologie de l'evolution on essaie
toujours de savoir si un comportement va
plutôt augmenter ou diminuer ce qu'on
appelle la valeur sélective d'un
individu vous ça fitness en anglais
c'est à dire grosso modo le nombre de
descendants qu'il va laisser à la
génération suivante les comportements
qui diminue la valeur sélective d'un
individu vont donc diminuer sa capacité
à se reproduire
et si les individus avec de tels
comportements ne se reproduise pas bah
alors comportement ne vont pas être
transmis aux générations futures et ses
comportements risque donc de disparaître
les comportements moraux en particulier
puisqu'ils vont à l'encontre de
l'intérêt personnel semble bien entrer
dans cette catégorie des comportements
qui diminue les chances de survie et in
fine et de reproduction et ça ça conduit
au paradoxe de la morale eh oui d'un
côté on a ces comportements moraux qu on
observe de façon relativement fréquente
son espèce humaine
et puis de l'autre côté on a la théorie
l'évolution qui nous dit que ces
comportements moraux ne devrait pas
exister parce qu'ils vont à l'encontre
de l'intérêt des individus parce qu'ils
sont coûteux comme on dit dans le
langage des biologistes comment des
comportements moraux ont-ils pu survivre
à l'état de nature vous invite vraiment
à mettre pause et à y réfléchir 30
souvenir
de plusieurs années voire même dizaine
d'années que les biologistes essaient de
résoudre ce paradoxe et l'idée générale
pour résoudre ce paradoxe de dire que
les comportements moraux ne sont coûteux
qu'en apparence parce qu'il procure
également des bénéfices mais des
bénéfices qui sont beaucoup plus caché
que les coûts au final si les
comportements moraux apporte plus de
bénéfices que de coûts le paradoxe est
résolu bien sûr il reste encore à
déterminer quel type de bénéfices
pourraient bien porter les comportements
moraux et là plusieurs hypothèses
coexistent une première hypothèse repose
sur ce qu'on appelle la sélection de
parentèle l'idée derrière la sélection
de parentèle c'est de dire que pour la
théorie de l'évolution ce qui est
important ce n'est pas qu'elle
d'individus bon se reproduire mais quels
gènes vont se reproduire
et quand on parle de comportements qui
vont avantager certains individus il
s'agit en fait d'un raccourci pour
parler de comportements qui vont
avantager les jeunes de c1 diminue c'est
ce que richard dawkins appel l'hypothèse
du gène égoïste et selon cette hypothèse
il faut considérer les individus comme
des sortes de machines au service des
jeunes qui les gouvernent
donc si les comportements moraux sont
dirigés vers des personnes très proches
génétiquement comme la famille proche
ce n'est pas grave qu'il soit coûteux
parce qu'ils vont apporter des bénéfices
à des personnes qui partagent les mêmes
gènes dans cette perspective un gène qui
causeraient pour un comportement moral
serait vu comme un gène qui aide une
copie de lui même à se reproduire mais
une copine lui même qui est présente
dans le corps d'un autre individu dans
une autre enveloppe charnelle celle d'un
parent proche cette hypothèse a eu un
succès retentissant au cours du dernier
demi siècle
la sélection de parentèle permet
d'expliquer des centaines et des
centaines de comportement coûteux dans
le monde du vivant
par exemple les abeilles et les fourmis
qui se sacrifie pour la colonie ou bien
les suricates qui se met en danger en
poussant des cris des larmes ou bien les
oiseaux qui vont apporter de la
nourriture aux nuits à des bébés qui
sont pas les leurs tous ces
comportements coûteux sont expliqués par
de la sélection de parentèle mais
l'hypothèse de la sélection de parentèle
semble aussi avoir ses limites en
particulier comment expliquer les
comportements moraux chez les humains le
problème avec les comportements moraux
c'est qu'ils sont très souvent dirigées
vers les personnes qui ne sont pas
proches génétiquement et dans certains
cas l'action morale va carrément à
l'encontre de la famille d'un exemple en
tête oui par exemple favoriser
l'ascension sociale de ses proches au
détriment d'autres
ce qu'on appelle le népotisme est
quelque chose qui est vu comme hautement
immoral par beaucoup et plus
généralement de nos jours la plupart
d'entre nous trouverions immoral et
demandé un test adn à quelqu'un avant de
choisir de l'aider ou non
et du coup il ya des chercheurs comme
stéphane qui ont cherché d'autres
explications à l'émergence et au
maintien des comportements moraux
l'hypothèse sur laquelle j'ai travaillé
pendant ma tête postule que les
bénéfices des comportements moraux c'est
d'être choisie plus souvent comme
partenaire social par exemple les m'as
promis un million d'euros et une
tablette de chocolat suisse pour faire
cette vidéo avec lui s'il ne me verse
pas cet argent non seulement je bosserai
plus jamais avec lui mais en plus je
n'hésiterai pas à aller crier sur tous
les toits qu'il m'a roulé ce qui fait
que plus personne ne voudra bosser avec
lui et à linverse s'il fait ce qu'il
avait promis je n'hésiterai pas à re
bosser avec lui et à lui construire une
bonne réputation chocolat arriver à
cette situation il a sûrement familière
dans la vie de tous les jours on essaie
toujours d'éviter d'interagir quand
c'est possible bien sûr avec les gens
qui sont pas bien comportés avec nous
les gens injuste inéquitable immoraux
dans le même genre la menace d'un
mauvais commentaires sur google ou
tripadvisor est souvent super utile pour
empêcher les hôtels et les restaurants
de vous maltraitez grâce aux
commentaires tout comportement moral est
immédiatement repéré et un vendeur qui
se comporteraient pas bien pour être
très vite coulé son business alors
aujourd'hui on voit plus ou moins s'en
sortir en se comportant de manière
immorale mais imaginez ce que ça aurait
pu donner il ya 50 ou 100 millions dans
l'environnement dans lequel on a évolué
pendant des centaines de milliers
d'années la coopération est omniprésente
et chasseurs cueilleurs coopèrent pour
chasser pour cuisiner pour construire
des abris pour se protéger des
prédateurs pour élever leurs enfants etc
etc et donc en vous comportant de façon
immorale vous fait exclure de ses
réseaux de coopération et vous payer
immédiatement un coût énorme qui a un
impact fort sur vos chances de survie et
de reproduction préserver sa réputation
de collaborateurs siad et moral était
sans doute une question de survie
d'où l'hypothèse selon laquelle les
bénéfices des comportements moraux c'est
de se faire choisir plus souvent comme
partenaire de coopération ou inversement
de moins se faire exclure des réseaux de
coopération
donc les comportements moraux sont
coûteux mais sur le long terme et la
porte plus de bénéfices que de coups
parce qu'ils permettent de rester
intégré au réseau de coopération et en
particulier les comportements trop
immoraux ce qui exclut les individus des
réseaux de coopération ont disparu telle
serait la clé de l'émergence et de la
survie des comportements moraux
alors c'est bien
comme hypothèse mais comment on la teste
le problème pour l'attester c'est que
l'évolution de comportements moraux a
probablement eu lieu sur des centaines
de milliers d'années et donc on peut
évidemment pas à remonter en arrière
pour essayer d'observer on peut pas non
plus la recréer en laboratoire
d'où une approche plus théorique et de
la biologie évolutionnaire et
saint-junien on pourra ainsi vouloir
vérifier le lien de cause à effet à
savoir prouvé mathématiquement que si
les individus choisissent leurs
partenaires et connaître les réputations
des uns et des autres alors la sélection
naturelle ne gardera que ceux aux
comportements moraux et la biologie du
mathématiques utile justement la théorie
des jeux pour prouver de quelle théorie
mais bien souvent mathématisée de tels
liens de cause à effet requiert une
simplification à outrance de la biologie
on peut alors préféré être plus preuve
de la biologie et s'éloigner des
mathématiques et ceci peut se faire à
l'aide de simulations numériques et
c'est ce qu'a fait stéphane imaginer que
la seule chose que vous allez faire dans
les 24 heures qui arrivent c'est essayer
de trouver d'autres personnes avec qui
collaborer pour produire des ressources
et que pour produire ces ressources vous
devez d'abord vous mettre d'accord sur
un partage
le but du jeu pour vous c'est d'avoir
accumulé le maximum de ressources au
bout de 24 heures est la question que je
vous pose c'est quel partage
allez-vous proposer aux autres personnes
est ce que vous allez leur donner le
moins possible l'avantagé tant que vous
garderez une grosse part de la ressource
pour vous mais en contrepartie vous
ferez moins choisir comme partenaire ou
est-ce que vous allez être très généreux
dans vos partages l'avantagé tant que
vous serez très souvent choisi comme
partenaire de coopération mais en
contrepartie vous garderez moins de la
ressource pour vous même dans chacune
des interactions on a là typiquement un
paradoxe de la morale a priori il vaut
mieux tout garder pour soi mais ça nuit
à la coopération
mais du coup stéphane comment as-tu
déterminer la valeur seuil qui des
individus en fonction de la manière dont
ils étaient prêts à partager et surtout
comment as tu pu montrer quelle
stratégie de partage
alès ou visiter ce que j'ai fait c'est
recréer l'évolution dans des ordinateurs
donc j'ai modéliser une population
d'individus qui doivent se partager des
ressources qu'ils ont produites en
coopérant et qu'ils peuvent pas dire
avec qui ils veulent coopérer sur la
base de leur réputation de partage pour
simplifier on va dire que à quel point l
individu et morale c'est à dire à quel
point le partage c'est qu'au départ un
seul gène c'est à dire que dans mon
modèle les individus auront un gène qui
va déterminer comment ils vont partager
et tout au long de sa vie chaque
individu va rencontrer des dizaines
d'autres individus
c'est ce gène de partage qui le
caractérise va déterminer s'ils
acceptent de coopérer et de produire des
ressources avec chacun des autres
individus qu'ils rencontrent arrivé à la
fin de sa vie chaque individu va se
reproduire en fonction des ressources
qu'il aura accumulé plus un individu
aura cumulé de ressources plus il
produira de descendants ça c'est la
sélection naturelle et de façon sociale
il y à aussi transmission du patrimoine
génétique tout à fait qu'un individu
produits indécent devant il lui transmet
son gène de partage avec éventuellement
plus ou moins une petite mutation comme
c'est le cas dans tout processus
évolutif et c'est là que ça devient
intéressant parce que en introduisant
des petites mutations
on est maintenant capable d'explorer
l'espace de stratégie de partage
possible en particulier fils y ait une
meilleure stratégie
grâce aux mutations il y aura forcément
un individu qui finira par l'adopter
mieux encore dans de tels jeux et à l'
équilibre on peut démontrer que les
gènes de la population correspondront
nécessairement à une sorte d'équilibré
de nage stable du jeu qui oppose les
gènes que l'on appelle les stratégies
évolutionnaire mans stable ou iss en
anglais tout ce qui nous reste à faire
c'est donc de faire tourner notre modèle
sur des mini de génération donc pendant
des milliers de générations on va
simuler des individus qui se choisissent
les uns aux autres qui accumule les
ressources et qu'ils se reproduisent
est ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va
regarder au bout d'une minute génération
quels sont les gènes de partage qui
subsistent dans la population et du coup
qu'est ce que tu as obtenu ce que les
modèles ont montré c'est que le seul
partage qui subsistent au bout de
milliers de générations c'est le partage
en deux parts égales c'est à dire que
dans un environnement dans lequel il est
nécessaire et possible d'être choisi
comme partenaire de coopération et dans
lequel il est nécessaire et possible de
choisir ses partenaires de coopération
le partage qui va maximiser votre valeur
sélective qui va maximiser votre nombre
de descendants
c'est un partage en deux parts égales
toutes choses étant égales par ailleurs
bien sûr
autrement dit il les partage qui sont
favorisés par la sélection naturelle
sondés partagent en deux parts égales
les individus qui donne moins qu'ils
sont trop égoïste ont tendance à moins
se faire choisir comme partenaire de
coopération et donc à moi se reproduire
au final les individus qui donne
beaucoup aux autres qu'ils sont très
généreux ils ont tendance à se faire
exploiter et donc au final ils se
reproduisent moi également
incroyable le devoir moral de partage
égalitaire que l'on retrouve à travers
le monde est une propriété émergente de
ce modèle saint tite de l'évolution
enfin on à la partage égalitaire en
partie parce que les individus de la
population sont tous identiques
notamment dans leur contribution à la
production économique
que se passerait il s'il y avait des
différences dans les capacités de
production j'ai aussi modéliser ce quart
en introduisant dans la population des
individus qui travaillent plus que
d'autres pour produire la ressource et
dans ce cas les modèles ont montré que
les gènes qui sont favorisés par la
sélection naturelle sont ceux qui
récompense les individus qui travaillent
le plus ce qui est à nouveau une
intuition morale assez répandue j'ai
également introduite des différentes de
force physique entre les individus et
les modèles ont montré que tant qu'il
est nécessaire d'être choisi comme
partenaire de coopération les individus
fort n'ont aucun intérêt à essayer de
profiter de leurs forces pour extorquer
des ressources aux individus les plus
faibles ce qui est à nouveau une
intuition morale assez répandu au final
ce que les modèles nous disent c'est que
si vous veniez de naître et que la seule
chose qui allait déterminer le nombre de
descendants que vous allez laisser à la
génération suivante c'est les ressources
que vous pouvez accumuler en coopérant
alors dans ce cas la meilleure chose que
vous puissiez faire c'est de partager
ses ressources en deux parts égales
quand vous avez travaillé autant que
votre partenaire et peu importe le
rapport de forces qu'il existe entre
vous ou alors donné plus de ses
ressources à votre partenaire s'il a
travaillé plus longtemps à nouveau peu
importe le rapport de forces qu'il
existe entre vous si on s'en réfère au
modèle de stéphane la morale ne sera
donc pas un devoir sacré fondamentale
elle ne serait qu'une conséquence de la
sélection naturelle et en particulier de
notre besoin de coopérer pour produire
les biens nécessaires à la survie et à
la reproduction
c'est assez contre intuitif mais c'est
bel et bien ce que suggèrent les
simulations de stéphane alors évidemment
ces modèles sont très simplifié il reste
encore plein de choses à tester en
particulier en ces concentrés ici sur un
type de comportement moral particulier
qui est le comportement de partage
et puis ces modèles ne nous disent rien
sur la validité d'autres hypothèses pour
essayer d'expliquer l'émergence de la
morale mais ça on en parlera dans les
deux prochaines vidéos
sion à cette vidéo vous peut retrouver
stéphane sûr c'est une chaîne youtube la
main baladeuse où il collabore avec les
artistes pour faire des vidéos de
garçons qui sont super sympas ces
quelques unes sur imad qui sont vraiment
cool et son autre chaîne qui est homo
fabulous où il parle un peu plus de son
domaine expertise à savoir la
psychologie évolutionnaire notamment sur
cet autre chaîne il ya une excellente
vidéo de stéphane où il expliquait
comment on choisit nos présidents 100
millisecondes plus en voyant les traits
des visages des candidats à la
présidentielle
on sait déjà un petit peu un choix sûr à
ce qu on va plutôt voté pour lui ou
plutôt pas et ça ça fait un petit peu
peur quand on y réfléchit
stéphane est aussi le président du café
des sciences qui est une association qui
regroupe pas mal de vulgarisateur sur le
web ce soit au format vidéo blog ou
bande dessinée vous aurez aussi du coup
allez voir le site du café des chances
si vous avez toujours que ce soit de
sciences au passage je me permet aussi
de vous recommander un petit jeu
interactif fait par nikki caisse
peut-être qu'il y en ait qui ont joué à
parable des polygones son avait parlé
dans l'épisode 6 qui correspondait déjà
un jeu interactif de meetic et initie
ges a sorti récemment un autre jeu
interactif pour illustrer l'évolution de
la coopération dans un environnement
dynamique et notamment avec des
propriétés de cet environnement qui
change évidemment elle facilité de
communication et d'erreurs au moment des
communications entre différents
individus
c'est super vincennes vos comptes
vraiment [ __ ] a fortement ce jeu qui
est au repos sur plusieurs notions
intéressante de théorie du jeu là d'un
fort on a parlé du rôle de la justice
notamment dans une société où on
admettrait qu'il n'y a pas de libre
arbitre et comment j'avais sorti les
arguments de la théorie des jeux pour
dire que ça pourrait être encore très
très utile pour donner les bombes
incentives aux citoyens pour qu'ils ne
fassent pas des trucs hydro verts
étaient nombreux à signaler qu'il ne
s'agissait pas du seul rôle de la
justice notamment dans une société où
n'y avait pas de libre arbitre
un autre rôle important de la justice
c'est la protection de la société civile
et j'imagine que quand vous entendez ça
vous entendez a posteriori c'est à dire
une fois que crime a été commis par du
coup un criminel on va vouloir mettre ce
criminel en prison pour empêcher une
nuit encore à la société dans une fesse
un point qui est tout à fait valable
même en l'absence de libre arbitre qui
peut être souhaitable de main
les criminels en dehors de la société
normale pour les empêcher de nuire à la
société un autre rôle important de la
justice a su ni par plusieurs parmi vous
c'est la réinsertion ou la rééducation
et personnes qui ont déjà commis un
crime qui est intéressant c'est que ces
deux points en fait ont été traités dans
le petit extrait d'interview que vous
avez passé de robert sapolsky est en
effet une autre raison tout à fait
valable mais comme le dit très bien
regarde sa peau si ce sont aussi des
choses qui pourraient être résolues par
d'autres manières que la justice en tout
cas qu'à lequel est impliqué aujourd'hui
notamment en imposant des contraintes et
des traitements adéquats pour les
différentes situations survie capable
comment de l'hérault perry pas que ce
sur quoi je voulais quand même insisté
parce qu'en fait un truc que j'ai trouvé
un petit peu déficient dont les
explications de fabrice qui sait
l'importance des punitions pour un
aspect purement incentive même si là
encore le théoricien des jeux sera
d'accord dire que le but ce n'est pas de
punir parce que question mérite quelque
chose de buts et de punir uniquement
pour rajouter les espèces de contraintes
finalement sur les initiatives ce que
les différentes personnes dans la
société vont avoir adrien dos santos se
demande si dans le cas de kevin du coup
les responsables n'étaient pas du coup
le chirurgien et si du coup je ne sais
pas ce qu'il faudrait punir
donc si j'utilise l' approche purement
théorie d essayer de donner bonne
synthèse de différentes personnes et
revoir question commence à punir les
chirurgiens parce qu'ils font ce genre
d'opérations qui ne sont pas capables
d'anticiper toutes les conséquences de
ces opérations
ça va donner tous les incentives aussi
chirurgien de ne pas faire ce genre
d'opération du coup de ne pas soigner de
ne pas chercher à soigner les gens qui
sont déjà victimes d'épilepsie au final
ça ça ferait peut-être moins bien en
forêt privée les pour le contre mais ça
pourrait être moins bien avec une
situation où les chirurgiens effectué ce
genre d'opération quitte à ce que dans
le cas il y ait certains cas qu'ils
soient un peu problématique comme le cas
de kevin parent il faudra kesher ainsi
peu à ça mais je suis pas sûr que du
coup punir les chirurgiens qui sont
auteurs de l'opération soit une solution
souhaitable en termes d'une scène type
enfin grecs york devant lequel il
scintille pourra être mise en place pour
diminuer lé envie de faire de lui
politique j'ai envie de dire que
malheureusement il ya une et roman de
structures aujourd'hui dans nos sociétés
qui favorise en fait ce qui donne d une
sainte il ça être un hooligan politique
déjà la demande de la politique ou si on
n'est pas convaincu d'un truc c'est
juste un petit de survivre à ces milieux
mais même dans le monde de l'entreprise
ou au monde du travail en général les
personnes qui sont extravertie qui
prennent position qui sont du coup très
loquace sont souvent plus avantagés
parce que par exemple ce sera aux
confidences au moment d'une promotion
est globalement il ya un petit billet
vert les gens qui sont très sûrs d'eux
dans la manière dont on sélectionne de
les futurs leaders de demain et c'est
d'ailleurs on le retrouve dans tout le
cursus scolaire où il est bien vue de
prendre des responsabilités de prendre
position et de diriger en étant sûr de
soi et en imposant sa façon de penser
qu'ils cassent nos impressions
personnelles et notamment suite à ma
formation d'ingénieur original j'ai
l'impression que des l'éducation mais
vachement en avant le fait d'avoir des
convictions ce même bien vu d'avoir des
convictions et de les affirmer encore
que ce cas dans le paysage politique on
me dit que quelqu'un qui n'a pas de
conviction
c'est un mauvais politiciens du coup
pour accéder à des postes à
responsabilité en fait tous les
incentives à prendre des positions
tranchées avec un certain humanisme
politique qui a complètement rejeté tous
les arguments opposés
donc malheureusement g20 faire que
l'hooliganisme poétique encore de beaux
jours devant lui
mon petit espoir notamment avec cette
série sur la démocratie c'est que la
notion de hooliganisme politiques soient
de plus en plus stigmatisant si bien que
ça finisse par être mal vu d'être
hooligans politique qui donc vous invite
à essayer de réutiliser ce terme autant
que possible dans la pratique notamment
pour convaincre quelqu'un que il se
trompe je pense que la première étape
c'est peut-être pas de lui dire qu'ils
se trompent
première étape c'est peut-être d'abord
de sweeney qui fait preuve publique et
nismo politique mais bon ça c'est un
petit peu mon avis personnel et c'est
peut-être un peu du we should cliquer
elle espère qu'il avait aimé cette
visite vous avez aimez cette vidéo
pensez à la ligue et à la commenter à la
partager quand ça vous abonner sont pas
en question les tisanes merci au keeper
paulo redon et j'espère qu'il serait là
la prochaine fois donc ce mini itx voir
du bon dans les actions altruistes et
socialement utile est une évolution
tardive de notre morale l'énergie pour
les deux soirs d'affilée
votre action a dit l'autre max noizet
ovale